mes chers amis
[Applaudissements]
je commence
merci
je commence par je commence par vous
partager
ce que vous ressentez puisque j'entends
c'est un immense sentiment de fierté une
fierté qui même si les résultats en
termes de siège ne sont pas à la hauteur
de nos attentes nous semblons en bonne
voie de terminer deuxième au scrutin
universel où on va voir si c'est que
c'est quoi
[Applaudissements]
nous avons démontré
nous avons démontré qu'il est possible
pour un parti indépendantiste de
s'assumer et de susciter de l'adhésion
en parlant sans détour de la cause qui
nous anime et ça c'est très important
pour la suite car non seulement nous
avons réussi une remontée qui remarquée
mais comme société nous avons retrouvé
le goût de la politique nous avons
retrouvé un amour du Québec comporte en
nous et ça ça fait vraiment du bien et
c'est grâce à vous
le projet d'indépendance du Québec
dévalorisée
voir mépriser pendant si longtemps par
les libéraux et maintenant par la CAQ ce
projet de décider par nous-mêmes
pour nous-mêmes celui des un pays normal
à l'échelle de l'histoire bien il
continue de susciter de l'espoir de
l'intérêt il continue de faire rêver et
de faire vibrer un grand nombre de
Québécoises et de Québécois
c'est un projet de société
c'est un projet de société qui remplit
de lumière et d'amour quand je vous
écoute je suis rempli d'espoir et j'ai
eu un mot pour les gens qui nous
regardent à la maison vous avez été des
centaines de milliers de personnes
à nous appuyer et à dire je veux voir
des indépendantistes à l'Assemblée
nationale vous nous avez donné le mandat
de se battre pour des choses
fondamentales comme l'avenir du français
l'avenir de l'environnement et des
changements climatiques des choses qui
vraiment nous tiennent à cœur donc à
tous ceux qui nous ont donné leur vote
merci du fond du cœur
nous sommes nous sommes au Québec en
date d'aujourd'hui plus de 2 millions
d'indépendantistes qui méritent une
représentation juste et équitable à
l’assemblée nationale et je crois que ce
nombre est appelé à croître au cours des
prochaines années donc non seulement il
nous faut une finition deuxième ou exéco
deuxième nous verrons le matin non
seulement nous avons fait une remontée
spectaculaire mais nous sommes aussi le
parti qui obtient les meilleurs
résultats en termes de deuxième choix et
surtout le parti qui aux yeux des
Québécois et des Québécoises amenaient
la meilleure campagne
donc le potentiel
le potentiel pour qu'un jour
le potentiel pour que nous vivions le
plus beau moment de l'histoire politique
du Québec le jour où on mettra au monde
notre pays le potentiel il est là le
potentiel il est radieux cet avenir là
même si on est dans un système
électoral qui vraisemblablement cause
une véritable distorsion je veux dire
rapidement un mot tout spécial aux
électeurs de Camille Laurin
simplement vous dire simplement vous
dire que ce sera un honneur pour moi de
vous représenter au cours des quatre
prochaines années Jean de tes Trouville
sur de l'arrondissement de mercis je
ferai tout pour être à la hauteur de ce
mandat mais surtout vous verrez en moi
un défendeur infatigable et très audible
de l'Est de Montréal trop souvent
délaissé
je veux évidemment féliciter François
Legault pour sa victoire qui est sans
équivoque on partage peut-être pas les
mêmes convictions quand on distingue du
Québec mais les Québécois ont tranché
ils ont choisi de continuer dans cette
voie pendant quatre ans c'est la
démocratie et nous la respectons
je prends ce moment pour saluer les
autres chefs de position Dominique
Anglade Gabriel Nadaud Dubois Éric Duhem
pour leur belle campagne
c'est pas tout repos ce que les chefs
d'oppositions viennent de vivre je le
souligne je pense qu'au-delà des
opinions des divergences d'opinions
qu'on peut avoir
faut reconnaître que pour chacun des
chefs de position la voix tracée était
loin d'être facile bravo aux autres
chefs de cette tenue debout pour leur
conviction malgré les vents contraires
donc
quoi retenir pour la suite les Québécois
ont décidé de continuer avec laque et je
crois que il faut s'assurer que dans ce
choix de continuer dans un chemin
on s'assure que on se perde pas en
chemin le seul chemin qui permet de
donner un avenir à notre langue
française à notre culture le seul qui
nous permettra d'être pleinement
pleinement nous-même et de rayonner à
travers le monde c'est celui de
l'indépendance
la même manière que pour les changements
climatiques
climatiques le seul chemin viable et
celui de la rigueur et du sens des
responsabilités donc au cours des
prochaines semaines des prochains mois
l'image de notre campagne je continuerai
une politique constructive qui ne
cherche pas des chicanes et des mises en
scène je continuerai ça avec Pascal
Bérubé et Joël Arsenault que je salue de
loin
nous serons fermés efficaces sur
l'essentiel mais pour tout ce qui peut
faire avancer le Québec nous ferons
avancer les choses et nous nous ferons
un point d'honneur de relever le débat
au Salon bleu
je vais mentionner aussi nos amis du
Bloc québécois qui nous ont aidés aux
quatre coins du Québec qui ont enfermé
haut et fort qu'ils sont
indépendantistes
un très grand merci à mon ami et
François Blanchette merci François pour
le soutien précieux
et maintenant à vous candidates et
candidats militants militantes ainsi que
les membres de notre grande formation
politique
le Parti québécois c'est l'histoire de
citoyens honnêtes qui rêvent à quelque
chose de mieux qui cogne à la porte des
voisins pour les convaincre que la un
avenir meilleur est possible des gens
qui organisent des assemblées de cuisine
des gens qui ne travaillent pas pour
eux-mêmes qui ne cherchent pas un
avantage mais qu'ils font par amour pour
le Québec cette longue tradition
politique initié par René Lévesque elle
a une valeur elle est précieuse
elle est formée de gens qui façonnent le
Québec comme on l'aime c'est à dire être
bienveillant être courageux et très rare
donc je vous remercie du fond du coeur
candidat candidate militant militante
les Québécoises de les Québécois nous
ont répondu c'est partout dans toutes
les indicateurs le système le mode de
scrutin je vais en parler à l'instant
c'est autre chose mais continuons ce
travail qui a été apprécié je remercie
les employés du parti qui ont vraiment
donné le meilleur de même
et je veux évidemment
sur une base plus personnelle remercier
mon épouse Alexandra pour son soutien
dans les hauts les bas de la politique
et pour tout le travail accompli dans
Camille Lorraine merci Alex
maintenant je me dois dès ce soir
d'aborder une question fondamentale à la
lumière des résultats que nous
reconnaissons et que nous acceptons se
posent des questions pourtant
très sérieuses est-ce normal qu'un parti
politique qui obtient environ 40% des
voix remportent 70% des sièges
qui obtient environ 15% des voix
n'obtiennent même pas 3% des sièges
est-ce normal qu'un parti politique
qu'obtienne 13% des voix n'obtiennent
aucune voie à l'Assemblée nationale
rarement dans notre histoire nous aurons
eu une telle disproportion entre la
volonté populaire et les résultats en
nombre de sièges et donc la dynamique
qui va y avoir à l'Assemblée nationale
une fois cette élection terminée
absolument rien n'empêche de réussir une
réforme du mode de scrutin rien
n'empêche la CAQ de revenir à son
engagement initial et de collaborer avec
tous les autres parties de position pour
qu'ensemble nous réussissions ce défi de
la démocratie
[Applaudissements]
je vais vraiment me consacrer à ce défi
là on a fait de la politique positive en
s'adressant à l'intelligence des gens
parce qu'on croit à la démocratie il y a
quelque chose qui cloche en ce moment
avec notre système et on est capable de
réussir ça en terminant je veux juste
vous dire que on a ressenti quelque
chose sur le terrain durant cette
campagne-là comme comme une comme une
lumière qui renaît puis que les gens
ressentent un amour qui dort en nous
pour le Québec et qu'on a je pense
réussi à réveiller
partout aux quatre coins de notre Québec
qu'on aime on a constaté cette énergie
celle des gens qui choisissent l'espoir
plutôt que la résignation
celle des gens
l'énergie et la luminosité des gens qui
tiennent toujours ou parfois même
tiennent pour la première fois notre
beau drapeau du Québec des gens dont les
yeux étaient remplis d'espoir
au-delà des résultats de la campagne en
terme de siège je pense que c'est ça qui
doit nous rendre fier ça faisait
longtemps en politique que nous n'avions
pas ressenti cela
on l'a ressenti pour l'entendu aussi les
gens nous demandent davantage de
politique constructives davantage
d'Idées claires il nous demande qu'on
continue à s'adresser à leur
intelligence mais c'est précisément ça
qu'on va continuer à faire
ce goût du Québec cette belle énergie
elle nous donne les moyens de relancer
notre cause elle nous donne l'espace
pour relancer une cause qui est noble
qui est juste qui est vrai et
profondément en créant dans notre passé
que dans notre avenir celle du droit des
Québécois de prendre eux-mêmes
démocratiquement leur décision au début
de cette campagne on a choisi le slogan
le Québec qui s'assume pour vrai et
c'est ce qu'on a fait s'assumer
pleinement
on a un privilège on a une mission mais
on a également un privilège de servir
une cause qui soit aussi noble et aussi
profondément ancré dans notre histoire
depuis les patriotes et je pense qu'on
peut dire sans se tromper
que nous avons fait en 36 jours
seulement la démonstration Kate fidèle
allait à ses convictions être
authentique être fidèle à ses rêves de
jeunesse être transparent quant à ce
qu'on pense véritablement mais c'est la
meilleure façon de faire avancer ses
idées politiques mais c'est également la
meilleure façon de faire avancer le
Québec
cette élection a démontré que nous
sommes des centaines de milliers à
retrouver par avoir le goût de
l'aventure collective le goût de
repousser nos limites le goût de
rayonner partout dans le monde et si
certains tentent de nous faire croire
que ce n'est plus un enjeu les
prochaines années ouvrent un chemin
qui bien qu'il ne soit pas facile va
apparaître très très clairement de
manière limpide de ludique
l'indépendance du Québec deviendra
nécessaire voir urgente à la lumière de
tendance très lourde des tendances
lourdes sur les thèmes fondamentaux du
français de l'environnement de la santé
de l'immigration de la culture des
relations internationales ces tendances
lourdes ne feront que s'aggraver et
notre devoir le sens des responsabilités
qui doit nous guider ne devra
qu'augmenter et l'écoute également
augmentera donc les années devant nous
sont passionnantes
c'est le temps de rassembler les
patriotes c'est le temps de rassembler
ceux qui aiment le Québec et ceux qui
entendent que notre destin national il
est devant nous et il est beau dans les
prochaines années d'ailleurs je vais
dédier mon temps à convaincre les jeunes
et les moins jeunes et les moins jeunes
car mon premier vote mon premier vote je
l'ai faite à 18 ans et c'était pour le
oui en 95 ce qui veut dire que tous ceux
qui ont moins de 45 ans ne se sont
jamais exprimés sur cette question
fondamentale donc prenons les prochaines
années pour rejoindre tout le monde avec
le seul projet de société qui
et porteur aussi grand mais très
réaliste également celui de notre
indépendance est comme disait Jacques
Parisot sortir par les convaincre c'est
ce que nous ferons
je termine simplement
[Applaudissements]
je termine simplement à vous design que
le destin du Québec est de devenir un
pays ce moment donnera un sens au
Patriote mais également la vie de René
Lévesque à celle de Jacques Parisot et
de tant d'autres car nous méritons à
l'échelle de l'histoire d'être un peuple
normal qui décide par lui-même nous
méritons de poursuivre cette fantastique
mais surtout improbable histoire d'un
peuple de langue française dans une
Amérique du Nord presque entièrement
anglophone et nous sommes le parti qui
travaillera sans relâche à la
réalisation de notre indépendance le
parti qui travaillera avec toutes les
énergies à renverser le déclin du
français le parti qui veut qu'on rayonne
partout dans le monde et aussi le parti
qui veut faire du Québec un pays vert un
pays respectueux de l'environnement
alors mes chers amis quand vous allez
vous coucher ce soir
quand les projecteurs seront fermés ayez
le coeur rempli d'espoir et je vous
laisse je vous laisse sur les mots de un
ou plus grand poète Gaston Miron
[Applaudissements]
ce soir nous ne sommes plus revenus pour
revenir nous sommes arrivés à ce qui
commence merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]